Alabama passes major anti-abortion
legislation that all but outlaws the
practice we will analyze the legal and
political fallout and examine the
question on everyone's mind will we see
the overturning of roe v wade in our
lifetimes
then another Democrat announces that he
is running for president this one is
number 728 I think of Stanford
University deans don't want Andrew
Klavan to speak on campus we will
examine the rot on our American
universities I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael an old show there is
so much BS going around about this
Alabama law today I have read the law I
have read the analyses of the law I have
read the history of this law we will
separate fact from fiction we've talked
a lot recently about the ethical and
moral questions of abortion so we're
gonna focus on the legal and political
consequences this could be one of the
most consequential moments in American
law in American history we'll we'll see
the likelihood of that but first let's
talk about something much more important
than the total changing of American law
going back to two foundational
principles let's talk about how I look
so good that's I think that's more
important Dollar Shave Club has
everything I need to look feel and smell
my best and what I love even more is the
fact that I never have to go to a store
because I am a millennial and I am very
lazy and I never want to replace my
toothpaste or my shaving cream or my
razors or any of that and thankfully I
don't have to because DSC delivers
everything I need right to my door they
also keep me fully stocked on what I use
so I don't run out so here's how it
works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe for your hair your skin your
face you can look just like this swarthy
man of Sicilian descent right here you
name it they have it and they have a new
program where they automatically keep
you stocked up on the products that you
actually use you determine what you want
when you want it and it shows up right
at your door once a month you can do it
or you can do it once every six months
so anything in between plus they have
their hands
some discount so the more you buy the
more you save right now they've got a
bunch of starter sets you can try for
just 5 bucks like their oral care kit I
love it after that the restock box ships
regular size products at regular price
what are you waiting for get your
starter set and then don't think about
this don't think about all I ran out of
the tube and I got to push it out and
wait three months to brush my teeth
properly don't do it get your starter
set for 5 bucks right now
dollarshaveclub.com slash coffe fa co v
fe fe dollarshaveclub.com slash co f fa
c OV e f EF en you will feel just as
good every day as i do major major
legislation i was thinking you know
we've talked a lot about abortion in the
last week but i think there's a reason
that we've done it this is the pro-life
moment we are at the pro-life moment and
so now we're past the ethical discussion
now we're talking about the legal and
political consequences of these laws so
this law and alabama it's called the
human life Protection Act the entire
purpose of this law is to challenge roe
v wade it's true it will restrict
abortion in Alabama it will almost
eliminate it that's good I actually
don't think that's the primary purpose
the primary purpose is to pose a direct
challenge to roe v wade which legalized
abortion throughout the United States
Alabama Senator Clyde Chambliss opened
up the debate on this by asking a series
of questions that gets right down to the
heart of roe v wade he asked when is a
person a person when does a life become
a life I believe if we terminate the
life of an unborn child we are putting
ourselves in God's place simple as that
when does a person become a person when
does a life become a life this abortion
law is being so misrepresented it by the
media and on social media this is a
landmark law that's why I mean this does
pose a real threat to roe v wade that's
why just to begin what does the law
actually say if you just read social
media in the mainstream media they'll
tell you that this law is going to put
women in jail for getting abortions this
light no it will not this law
explicitly does not punish women who get
abortions I'll say that again this law
very explicitly does not punish any
woman who will get an abortion anybody
telling you otherwise is lying here it
is right in the text of the law section
5 quote no woman upon whom an abortion
is performed or attempted to be
performed shall be criminally or civilly
liable furthermore no physician
confirming the serious health risk to
the child's mother shall be criminally
or Cilla civilly liable for those
actions so even in the case of abortion
providers if the there is a legitimate
risk to the life of the mother that
doctor will not be held liable now that
doesn't mean a risk to the mental health
of the mother doesn't mean a risk to the
financial health of the mother it means
a serious risk to the life of the mother
if she has this child she will die or or
even if she has this child she's so
mentally ill that she will kill herself
or kill her or kill the baby or enter
pregnancy later on then you can get an
abortion the doctor won't be held liable
and in no case will the woman getting
the abortion be held liable however in
all other cases according to this law
abortion performed in violation of this
act is a Class A felony and an attempted
abortion performed in violation of this
act is a Class C felony
so doctors who perform abortions not in
the very very rare case of a risk to the
life of the mother
all other abortions could receive up to
99 years in prison now the example that
people are using on the internet now is
they're saying you're telling me that a
doctor who performs an abortion will
spend more time in prison than the
rapist incestuous person who rapes a
twelve-year-old girl
and impregnates her that's that's the
the meme that's going around they're
using all of those parts the doctor goes
to prison long
then the incest rapist of a
twelve-year-old girl first of all this
is a very rich analogy coming from
people who just in the last presidential
election voted for a woman who literally
defended the rapists of a actual
twelve-year-old girl
in litigation in a case she Hillary
Clinton defended the rapist of a
twelve-year-old girl even though she
joked about how she knew he was guilty
we have it on tape that she joked about
and she knew he was guilty so that's
okay you can you can vote for the rape
the person who defended the rapist of a
twelve-year-old girl but now you're
going to demagogue on that issue to save
a million babies per year first of all
by the way on the question of abortion
rape incest life of the mother those the
three that the left always wants to talk
about make up less than 1% of abortions
annually and in the indicate the awful
case of rape or incest that's terrible
but but what about the baby if the logic
of abortion is that the baby is not a
baby as that gentleman that I talked to
in Philadelphia the other day said a
baby is not a baby that's the logic of
abortion the logic of pro-life is a baby
is a baby so if a baby is a baby then in
that in the awful case of rape or incest
the logic doesn't break down now I mean
I think we should kill the rapist I
think it's perfect it would be perfectly
fine to use capital punishment to kill
all the rapists in the country that's
fine by me it doesn't change the
question of the baby also they say that
the doctor will be punished more than
the rapist right in our legal system
murder is considered a more serious
crime than rape so if if abortion is
morally equivalent to murder then right
that's what will happen that's what the
law says right now the the law goes
further the law in the text of it says
quote it defines a person for homicide
purposes to include an unborn child in
utero
at any stage of development regardless
of viability and it was at this point
reading through the Alabama law that I
realized this is the opposite of the New
York abortion law that New York abortion
law that was just passed the
reproductive health act goes so extreme
in the other direction then it says you
can kill a baby at any time up until the
moment of birth and it actually changes
the penal law to say that if you kill a
pregnant woman it's no longer a double
murder now it's only a single murder and
what this does is it defines a person
for homicide versus person purposes as
including an unborn child now of course
when the New York law passed the
mainstream media thought it was just
fine and dandy the Empire State Building
was lit up pink the World Trade Center
was lit up pink there were celebrations
oh I was perfectly fine this of course
not
there's an interesting phenomenon that's
going on right now that is even beyond
the abortion question which is that the
liberal states are getting more liberal
and the conservative states are getting
more conservative and specifically on
this question of abortion the
pro-abortion states are becoming
radically pro-abortion kill a baby while
he's being born kill a baby after he's
been born if you take the governor of
Virginia at his word that's on the one
side on the other side babies or babies
and you can't kill them regardless of
the reason that you want to kill them
the irony here is that roe v wade was
supposed to stop this before roe v wade
the the public opinion in the United
States was moving in favor of abortion
if you had not had this blanket roe v
wade decision that invented a
constitutional right to abortion and
legalized abortion throughout the United
States you would have what you had
before some states you'd have legal
abortion some states you'd have you
wouldn't have legal abortion and at that
time states were moving in the direction
of legalizing abortion now maybe that
would have changed over time this is one
of the features of our system of
self-government is as circumstances
change as our understanding of the law
changes as our understanding of
ourselves change
we can change the laws now roe v wade
stopped that roe v wade halted that
entirely they said we can't keep having
this state-by-state debate over abortion
we need one federal law for everybody so
they did that and guess what happened
the debate only got more intense guess
what happened
public opinion began to turn in favor of
pro-life this is the case for federalism
here the attempts to quash federalism
the attempts to have a blanket rule for
everybody don't work we'll see why they
don't work in a second but now let's
talk about the numbers let's get into
our numbers if you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
the problem growing businesses have that
keeps them from growing knowing their
numbers is they have this hodgepodge of
business systems they have one system
for accounting another system for sales
another system for inventory another
system that they're great Aunt Martha
told them they had to use I don't know
they've got this huge inefficient mess
and what does that do if you've ever
worked in a business a small business or
you've operated a business it takes up
too much time and takes up too many
resources that hurts the bottom line
introducing NetSuite by Oracle the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business in
an easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you need to
grow with NetSuite you save time money
and unneeded headaches by managing sales
finance accounting orders HR instantly
right from your desktop or phone that is
why NetSuite is the world's number one
cloud business system don't waste time
don't waste money you could seriously
imperil the the life of your business
if you have all these crazy systems that
don't work with each other they don't
talk to each other and you're just not
tracking data is king don't lose sight
of that right now NetSuite is offering
you valuable insights with a free guide
seven key strategies to grow your
profits and NetSuite comm slash Knowles
kano wles
NetSuite comm slash Knowles to download
your free guide seven key strata
to grow your profits NetSuite comm /
Knowles canna wles so roe v-- wade was
gonna stop this debate over abortion
what happened the abortion debate got
even more intense now i think
conservatives here basically need to be
in favor of federalism the argument here
for the abortion law in Alabama or
Georgia or wherever else Missouri
wherever else their income is states
need to be able to decide this for
themselves roe v-- wade is a made-up
constant it creates a totally fictitious
constitutional right there should not be
a blanket permit for abortion throughout
the whole country it doesn't make any
sense we need to support federalism we
need to support states rights here in no
small part because the attempts to stop
federalism the attempts to stop the
states from doing what they want just
don't work New York is very different
from Alabama and I know that the Supreme
Court really wants to make New York
exactly like Alabama they're not they
have different values in many cases they
have different cultures they have
different people and they they want to
live differently and you shouldn't force
Alabama to live like New York you
shouldn't force New York to live like
Alabama and regardless of should or
ought to or the the which side is more
right I'm just telling you as a fact a
historical fact it doesn't work it's so
ridiculous to try to make New York into
Alabama its it's just a fool's errand
it's never going to work now the by the
way the last time that we tried to quash
of federalism here the the the last time
that we faced a question like this was
slavery this is the last time we faced
an intense moral question of the level
should we kill a million babies a year
and and it's true we solved that problem
by the top-down and by saying no there's
gonna be a blanket rule now for the
entire country good thing that we did it
it did cost us five years of war in the
deaths of 600,000 Americans that's the
stakes that
we're talking about here you if you if
you honestly think that we're gonna go
into a civil war rip the country apart
and kill now much more than 600,000
Americans okay but that's the stakes
otherwise federalism does provide
another option here on this question at
least for now the bill then goes on so
it talks about look we're not going to
punish women for getting abortions we
are going to punish doctors except in
this one case then the bill invokes
explicit moral language so the bill bill
then invokes the Declaration of
Independence the Holocaust the communist
gulags
and genocides throughout history this is
very serious stuff this is a bill that
is meant to be read by the supreme court
to challenge this question they write
quote in the United States Declaration
of Independence the principle of natural
law that all men are created equal was
articulated the self-evident truth found
in natural law that all human beings are
equal from creation was at least one of
the bases for the anti-slavery movement
the women's suffrage movement the
Nuremberg war crimes trials in the
American Civil Rights Movement
if those movements had not been able to
appeal to the truth of universal human
equality they could not have been
successful it is estimated that six
million Jewish people were murdered in
German concentration camps during World
War two three million people were
executed by Joseph Stalin's regime in
Soviet gulags two and a half million
people were murdered during the Chinese
Great Leap Forward in 1958 one and a
half million to three million people
were murdered by the Khmer Rouge in
Cambodia during the 1970s and
approximately 1 million people were
murdered during the Rwandan genocide in
1994 all of these are widely
acknowledged to have been crimes against
humanity by comparison by comparison
more than 50 million babies have been
aborted in the United States since the
ROE decision in 1973 more than three
times the number who were killed in
german death camps chinese purges
Stalin's gulags cambodian killing fields
and the Rwandan genocide combined this
is not just a dry matter of the law for
these Alabama legislators they are
putting this issue into stark relief we
talk about awful genocides throughout
history the numbers are unfathomable six
million three million one and a half
million all these numbers fifty to sixty
million babies since roe v-- wade fifty
to sixty million people who would be
alive who would have lived who would
have been born who are not born just to
think about that we're a country of 330
million people about imagine an extra 50
or 60 million of them by the way this is
just since 1973 virtually all of them
would still be alive
imagine how many more people we'd have
that's what this law is making
explicitly clear and that's what the law
actually says you can read it yourself
it's not a very long law fortunately the
Alabama legislators have some common
sense on them and they don't need to
write 300-page laws like some of our
federal legislators do in Washington so
you can read it go I encourage you to go
read it because you can tell on Twitter
which pundits have read the lawn which
haven't read the law you can tell very
clearly because the law is explicit and
if someone is telling you it's going to
punish women or something like just it
is not true now the left largely has not
read the law so they're losing their
mind on this here is the Democrat
representative from Alabama
Bobby singleton who's trying to stop
this bill before it's passed
so I don't think that Bobby singleton
has his metaphors quite right because he
said you aborted the state of Alabama
and then he says Alabama was pregnant
with this bill and you aborted her but
if it was the abortion it would be that
that someone else was pregnant with the
state of Alabama right it would be or if
they have rejected the bill they would
have aborted the bill but they didn't
abort the state of Alabama the other
look this is obviously not the brightest
bulb in the pack but something worth
noting here is this guy's entire
diatribe is you have aborted the state
of an Alabama you've committed an
abortion on the state of Alabama what
he's implying here is that abortion is a
very bad thing right he's actually in
his rhetoric he's undercutting his
entire argument because what he's trying
to say is that abortion is really good
and we should protect abortion and the
way he's doing that is saying you guys
have just done something so bad so in
defensively bad that you've committed an
abortion by outlawing abortion okay
maybe he should have thought that one
through or giving it to a staffer or
somebody to read beforehand other people
media figures or up in arms about this
john fugelsang it was a left-wing
comedian and radio host he tweeted out
quote Alabama rapists thank the state
GOP for finally giving every one of them
the option to pick the mother of their
next child okay again the case of rape
accounts for virtually no abortions per
year far less than 1% per year in the
case of rape
and also I mean just what he's saying is
not true there were 36 couples for every
one baby who is who is given up for
adoption who want to adopt that baby so
no you you the the rapist does not get
to pick the mother of his next child
because that baby can be given up for
adoption and there are many many many
people in this country who want to adopt
that baby
Amnesty International sort of ironically
named organization just tweeted out
quote abortion bans like the one passed
in Alabama are a violation of human
rights these bands will be deadly
they will endanger pregnant people's
lives
we must not go back so abortion bans are
a violation of Human Rights
killing a million babies a year not a
violation of Human Rights
abortion bans violation of Human Rights
the bands will be deadly so at this law
that they just passed not dead or that
the law is deadly killing a million
babies a year not deadly it will
endanger people's lives well that
actually says it will endanger pregnant
people's lives there was just no
justification for that at all this is
based on a lie that came out of the
pro-abortion movement they said that
before roe v-- wade five to ten thousand
women per year were killed from illegal
abortions that is completely made up the
guy who invented that number dr. Bernard
Nathanson who was one of the founders of
naradha pro-abortion
organization he has admitted in later
years after he became a pro-life
advocate that the number was plucked out
of thin air to to just be useful
propaganda we we actually know how many
women were killed the year before roe v
wade from illegal abortions it's not ten
thousand it's not five thousand it's
thirty nine people thirty nine people
killed from illegal abortions that year
twenty four women killed from legal
abortions that year and and then even
more when you factor in how many states
abortion was legal in and how many
states it was illegal in you find out
that the likelihood of dying from an
illegal abortion that year was exactly
the same as the likelihood of dying from
a legal abortion there was no difference
whatsoever and virtually no women a very
very small number of women actually died
from either of them so it won't endanger
pregnant people's lives at all that's
just a total lie
it the only thing endangering people's
lives is abortion which again kills a
million babies a year so what does this
mean for Roe what does this law mean for
the landmark decision I don't think that
this law is going to lead to the
overturning of roe v wade I don't I
don't think I really wish it would I do
not think that the Supreme Court is
going to overturn roe v wade I will tell
you why in a second but first we got to
go to Daily wire.com and so much more to
get to him we have this new Democrat in
the race and he launched his campaign
unfortunately with one of the most
cringe inducing videos of the entire
race which is really saying something
then poor Andrew Clavin our buddy is
being accosted by the administration of
Stanford University we'll get to the
heart of what's going on there and also
did you hear that did you hear it sounds
like bells chiming or birds singing and
that's because it's almost time for our
next episode of the conversation
featuring little old me I will give you
pearls of wisdom tomorrow at 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific I'll be taking
all of your questions every query that
has burned in your hearts I will answer
them live on the air plus Alicia crafts
will also be there so you know that'll
be nice as always this episode will be
free for everyone to watch on Facebook
and YouTube but only subscribers can ask
the questions once again subscribe to
get your questions answered by me
tomorrow 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
and join the conversation
daily wire.com you know you get
everything most importantly you get the
leftist here's tumblr you're going to
need that because of this abortion law
because we're not gonna keep killing all
those babies every year in Alabama drink
up the left is furious we'll see you in
a few seconds
I wish that this law would eventually
lead to the overturning of roe v wade I
don't think it's going to Y so roe v
wade for those of you who don't know is
the landmark Supreme Court decision in
the 1970s which legalized abortions were
at the country how did it do it it
justified this abortion right in the
Constitution under the general right to
privacy so this is what the court found
from roe v wade quote this right to
privacy whether it be founded in the
14th Amendment's concept of personal
liberty and restrictions upon state
action as we feel it is or in the ninth
amendments reservation of rights to the
people is broad enough to encompass a
woman's decision whether or not to
terminate her pregnancy
we need not resolve the difficult issue
of when life begins when those trained
in the respective disciplines of
medicine philosophy and theology are
unable to arrive at any consensus the
judiciary in this point in the
development of man's knowledge is not in
a position to speculate as to the answer
this is really rich coming from this
Supreme Court because there on the one
hand they're saying we're going to
invent a new constitutional right and
where is it I mean we can't really find
it but I don't know since in the 14th
amendment or the ninth of men Minds and
one of those amendments write it
somewhere so they say that on the one
hand and then they say when does life
begin gosh we could never we could never
know that we would never presume to tell
you when life begins
well you just presumed to invent a
completely new right in the Constitution
so I don't know I figured you could
answer the simplest question ever let me
give you a little biology lesson Supreme
Court when mommy and daddy love each
other very much and then the sperm and
an egg meet and the sperm fertilizes the
egg that's when life begins meets every
scientific definition of life and it's
obviously the case they can no they
won't answer that one so they say that
there's this right you know in the 14th
or the ninth or whatever let's say that
there is that right certainly the right
to privacy is trumped by the right to
life right I know the court knew that
that's why the court had to include that
extra language but we don't know when
life
begins yes we do we do know when life
begins but the court wanted to invent a
national right to abortion so they
invented it now there was a great
dissent from justice Byron white here
Byron white was not mincing words he
wrote quote I find nothing in the
language or history of the Constitution
to support the courts judgment the court
simply fashions and announces a new
constitutional right for pregnant women
and with scarcely any reason or
Authority for its action in vests that
write with sufficient substance to
override most existing state abortion
statutes now Justice William Rehnquist
also dissented here and Justice William
Rehnquist Irwin went on became becomes
the chief justice of the court he
pointed out what a judge justice white
was implying
if the Fourteenth Amendment protects
abortion as the court starts to say this
was apparently unknown to the people who
wrote the Fourteenth Amendment and also
to the people who enacted the Fourteenth
Amendment who ratified it the first
state law dealing directly with abortion
came in 1821 it was enacted by the state
of Connecticut the Fourteenth Amendment
was adopted 47 years later at the time
that the 14th amendment was adopted at
least 36 laws by states or territories
limited abortion and 21 of those laws
were still on the books at the time of
roe v wade so there's just no argument
at all for for the Fourteenth Amendment
argument or for Roe versus Wade and
that's why there are 22 cases right now
on their way to the court that
challenged roe v wade in indiana there
was a bill signed into law by then
Governor Mike Pence this required an
ultrasound and an 18 hour waiting period
before you could get an abortion there's
a case before the Court of Appeals for
the DC Circuit that invokes a it
involves a challenge to the Health and
Human Services policy that prevents
illegal aliens and us custody from
getting abortions Alabama previously had
included a personhood clause in their
state constitution to recognize the
rights of babies who haven't been born
yet
West Virginia stripped abortion rights
protections from its state constitution
and in Iowa the governor Kim Reynolds
signed a heartbeat bill into law you
heard that name right Kim Reynolds this
is another funny aspect of the abortion
debate here is you hear the left talking
about how awful this abort Alabama law
is it's going to destroy women it's anti
woman it's meant to punish women I can't
wait for those left wingers to find out
that the governor of Alabama is a woman
they don't know nobody seems to know
this the governor of Alabama is a woman
the woman who is going to sign this law
into effect is in fact a woman now don't
get too excited because everyone's
thinking now is the time the pro-life
movement has momentum we can do it we've
got rallies we've got laws we've got
state legislators we've got we've got
everything right Trump is in office
we've got a bunch of good judges we have
a two new judges on the Supreme Court we
have a conservative court right doesn't
matter I don't think we're gonna
overturn roe v wade republican
appointees on the court disappoint their
parties and their presidents all the
time and specifically on this issue
we've already seen this happen before we
saw this happen in 1992 in Planned
Parenthood v Casey this was a case
regarding the constitutionality of
Pennsylvania restrictions on abortion
and remember 1992 weren't coming just
out of the bush era were coming before
that just out of the Reagan era the
Reagan Revolution were at the height of
conservatism at that time years of
Reagan and Bush appointees on the courts
and what happened the court upheld quote
matters involving the most intimate and
personal choices a person may make in a
lifetime choice is central to personal
dignity and autonomy are central to the
Liberty protected by the Fourteenth
Amendment the court upheld the right to
an abortion it permitted some exceptions
and restrictions gave time periods when
you could have restrictions for some
reason I don't know I know I don't think
the drafters of the 14th amendment said
you can only have abortions before 25
weeks or something but whether but they
just invented that because you because
if you start with a Bab decision
then the only way to uphold it is to
write more bad decisions if you start
with a mess you're gonna keep the mess
going and so they upheld this right to
an abortion in here and it wasn't just
liberals it was Anthony Kennedy
appointed by Ronald Reagan it was David
Souter appointed by George Bush he was
Sandra Day O'Connor appointed by Ronald
Reagan three GOP Court appointees voted
to uphold roe v wade and the right to an
abortion and I think we're in for this
again I think Roberts is a total squish
I think Cavanaugh has intimated that
he's something of a squish and let's not
forget the court follows election
returns we like to pretend that the
court is this totally removed body
totally dignified but I wish that were
the case but it's not true the court
follows the election returns and they
especially Justice Roberts wants to
maintain the integrity of the court
which ironically means not having any
integrity on the court and just going
with with popular opinion that's what he
did on the Obamacare decision there's no
real argument to uphold Obamacare he
just kind of said oh well it's a mandate
for this purpose and a tax for this
purpose and basically I just don't want
to be really unpopular and people to
hate me well we're headed for it again
according to the Kaiser Family
Foundation sixty-seven percent of
Americans do not want the court to
overturn roe v wade that's not a simple
majority that's two-thirds of Americans
even among Republicans only 53% of
Republicans support overturning roe v
wade 43% oppose overturning roe v wade
so what's the likely legal and political
outcome probably they'll whittle away at
roe v wade they'll come up with some new
restrictions that are permitted for some
reason in the 14th amendment or whatever
I think this is a mistake I think that
we should return this issue entirely to
the states the Constitution doesn't
weigh in one way or the other there is
no prohibition of abortion in the
Constitution there is no right to
abortion in the Constitution it's just
not there
Antonin Scalia used to say not
everything hateful or odious is covered
by some provision of the Constitution
there are plenty of things that are s
b/c stupid but constitutional such as
the the ability of states to make the
run abortion laws sure but it's just not
in the Constitution so we have to return
this to the states
probably it's most prudent not to pass a
federal ban on abortion either
I'd like a federal ban on abortion if I
were the king I would have a federal ban
on abortion but I'm not the king and if
you have a federal ban you basically
keep this issue in the exact same state
of flux don't you it's just the opposite
of roe v wade so if the court found
abortion is is prohibited by some
provision of the Constitution you just
say you'd have the same thing in the
other direction or even one step further
let's say that the court finds what is
correct which is that abortion is not
covered by the Constitution should we
then enact a constitutional amendment I
suppose I would be in favor of one but
you are risking that the same issue that
we've had with abortion for the last 50
60 years which is if you return it to
the States if you return it to the
laboratories of democracy I do have
faith in the people that they will come
to the correct conclusion eventually I'm
a little wary of a constitutional
amendment to prohibit all abortions
because I do have faith in the people
and I have faith in science and as
scientific advancements progressed we're
realizing earlier and earlier Oh a baby
really is a baby people are realizing
this public opinion now unlike at the
time of roe v wade is all in favor of
the pro-life side if we if we just trust
in our foundational institutions our
system of government our people
I think momentum is moving in our
direction but I'm not too excited I'm
not I'm not that hopeful I think we're
gonna get more squishes on the court I
think very likely we're going to see a
repeat of of 1992 and Planned Parenthood
v Casey
we're just gonna have to wait and see
Alabama's doing exactly what they should
be doing the pro-life movement is doing
exactly what they should be doing and
let's hope and let's put a little
pressure on our Supreme Court justices
to do what they should be doing as well
this is related to another story today
would I mean this is a pretty simple
story
the US has hit the lowest birth rate in
32 years this is part of a decades-long
trend we are now down in the year 2018
down in births 2% from the year before
that it's a pretty big drop we now have
only 1.73 births per 1,000 women of
childbearing age I only bring up this
story to point out if you overturned Roe
if you got rid of abortion that problem
would be over there would be in
countries require about a 2 or 2 point
one birth rate we're now at a 1.7 3
birth rate if you get rid of Roe that
problem is fixed there were there were
three million seven hundred eighty eight
thousand live births in 2018 we killed a
million babies that same year you could
have had four million seven hundred
eighty eight thousand births think about
that year over year after year you'd
also have a lot more black people by the
way just as a side note Allah this is
one reason why a lot of white
supremacist types actually support
abortion is because black babies are
aborted between three and four times as
frequently as white babies so if the
left wants to end white supremacy which
does not exist in this country but let's
say that it did if the left wanted to
end that you'd think that they would
want to overturn Roe versus Wade now
they don't it's just words words words
the other thing that would happen if you
overturned Roe vs. Wade and you stopped
killing a million babies a year you'd
solve the immigration problem the reason
why neither political party actually
wants to solve the immigration problem
is that economically we need the
immigrants our population is dying
we have 1.7 birthrate we're not
replacing ourselves the only way that we
keep this economy growing is by bringing
people in from the third world or from
wherever I
publicans acknowledged in this to the
chamber of commerce knows this I mean
the Wall Street Journal Republican types
they all know that but if you stopped
killing a million babies a year that
need that economic need would would go
away would be vastly diminished it just
reminds us abortion is not just a social
issue that's how some people want to
portray it it's an economic issue it's a
demographic issue and it's a legal issue
as well completely changing topics from
the Alabama abortion law which is
basically the only news of the day but
we have to cover this guy he's not in
the news and he's probably never gonna
make it into the news but I hope he does
he's the newest Democrat in the twenty
twenty primary race his name is Steve
Bullock and he is the governor of
Montana and he's not ever gonna be
President but the reason I hope he makes
it to the debate stage I'm considering
donating money to him because I want him
on the debate stage he was asked on
c-span after being governor for seven
years
almost seven years what he was most
proud of here's what he said this man
I am happy that hopefully my kids still
know my most important job is being
their dad I think the things where you
know as governor it's not like Attorney
General and you know you won or lost
awkward what are you proudest of no I'm
gonna homina homina well hmm let me well
I I'm I'm a dad I guess we are back to
the roe v-- wade question this week it's
everything leads back to abortion this
week that's what you're proud of stuff
no she said what are you but governor
for seven years or whatever what are you
proud of stuff I I don't know that's a
softball governor that you're supposed
to know the answer to that one she's not
grilling you here it's so brutal the guy
the guy can't name one thing that he's
proud of doing is governor so he's gonna
run for president what this shows you is
that this presidential nomination for
Democrats is any man's race what this
shows you is there's no actual obvious
nominee it shows you that the field is
pretty weak if guys like this are
getting into the race if you got now
what 22 people in the race it shows you
this field is really really weak and I
assume he's going nowhere but it you
know people are talking about Joe Biden
a lot now the president is talking about
Joe Biden because he's he's leading over
the other candidates he's a weak if he
were the obvious nominee all these guys
wouldn't be getting into it hopefully he
can come up with an answer to what are
you proud of accomplishing before he
gets onto the debate stage another one
governor just a little bit of advice
people are gonna ask you what you want
to do as president you should you should
also probably have an answer for that
presumably if you don't have an answer
for what you've done you probably won't
have an answer for what you want to do
but you've got a little bit of time
before the debates also got a point out
here our pal Andrew Clavin that vicious
Islamophobic bigoted monster is
not very welcome at Stanford University
right now one of the nation's leading
universities he has caused chaos and
mayhem on campus he was invited to give
a talk on America's judeo-christian
values pretty basic stuff and he's
facing staunch opposition not from the
students by the way from the
administrators the administrators there
Suzie Baker Cole who's the vice provost
of the University and Tiffany Stein work
dean for religious life wrote a letter
strongly opposing him
they wrote quote while our university
welcomes discussion of all aspects of
America's religious diversity were
deeply troubled by views Clavin has
expressed in the past in relation to
Islam we believe it is possible to
affirm one's own faith traditions
without denigrating or distorting those
of others
what has drew said about Islam what what
do they not like they obviously don't
give any specific examples because they
can't because I mean Druze talked about
Islam usse talked about a whole number
of issues but they can't give the
specifics they just say he's
Islamophobic which is completely made-up
word that means nothing and then he says
it's possible to affirm one's faith
traditions without denigrating or
distorting others first of all Drude
hasn't distorted islam ever show me an
example of one but what they're saying
is you can say some nice things about
Christianity but you can't discuss other
religions because if I'm going to extol
the virtues of Christianity then I am
necessarily contrasting the views of
Christianity with other religious
systems just to use a simple example the
god of Christianity is pure logic he is
the logos is the divine logic of the
universe the God of Islam Allah is pure
will so the the great Muslim theologian
even hasn't writes that the the God of
Islam Allah is so purely will that he is
not bound by any sort of logic if if
Allah tells you to worship an idol you
would be bound to do that
those are those are different views of
God those are very different views and
one of them is correct and one of them
is incorrect so if I say god is the god
of logic that necessarily means that the
God of Islam is is not really God that
the Islamic view of of God is not true
you you can you actually cannot affirm
your own faith traditions without
necessarily claiming that the others are
false but then then they go on they get
even more intense about this they say we
understand it can be frustrating and
painful deeply frustrating and painful
to see speakers invited to campus whose
ideologies disparage members of our
community again show me an example Druze
never disparaged any member of the
community acknowledging this pain we
nonetheless encourage you to look beyond
the sensationalism of speakers whose
currency is controversy to the examples
of people joining together across
difference and standing in solidarity in
the face of hatred and slander hatred
and slander you're the only one
promoting hatred and slander also people
whose currency is controversy Andrew
Klay hate to say nice things about drew
Andrew Clayman is a best-selling
novelist who's written about a zillion
books he's an award-winning writer of
fiction he's written a lot of very big
Hollywood movies what have these women
ever done Suzi Brubaker and Tiffany
Stein word the only thing I know about
them is they try to stir up controversy
from their completely useless positions
in the bloated administration of
Stanford what they're accusing drew of
is what they are doing themselves and
then this is pretty troubling they say
well they accused her of violence they
say violence has shattered many
communities but nonetheless we stand
together they imply that he's being
violent and then they say as you decide
how to respond to this speaker and
others who may follow we encourage you
to have hope in the communities of
solidarity as you decide how to respond
they sound like mobsters listen sure
would be a shame if somebody came up and
responded to your or speech huh yes it
would be a dirty rotten shame as you the
way to respond to a speaker at a
university that you disagree with is
that you listen to what he has to say
and then you express your opinion
there's one way to respond the the idid
that she's pushing that there are
multiple ways to respond implies that
students could shout him down students
could drown him out students could get
violent as this happened to me and other
people at universities that's the
implication here and it's obviously the
implication that the reason I bring this
up not just a defender he's a big boy he
can defend himself the administrators of
the problem you know there are those
kind of childish idiots it like the girl
at Yale who was shouting your this is
this is a safe space
your is screaming the F word at her
professor who hired you all this kind of
stuff this is not an intellectual
community she shouted it's easy to
vilify the students and the students are
complete idiots that's true and that
girl in the Yale video is a privileged
bratty little child students are
ignorant and uneducated and badly
behaved by definition that's what a
student is the issue is the
administration the issue is Susie
Brubaker Cole and Tiffany Stein worked
at Stanford the issue at Missouri is
that jerk
Chancellor Molly agrawal who after I was
physically assaulted smeared me as a
bigot and defended the hecklers veto
that's the issue there the there of the
problem because they should know better
and they don't so what we should do is
defund these universities that tolerate
this stuff at a public level we should
stop donating as alumni at the private
level and the demand should be clear
fire the administrators stop the bloat I
get why they kowtow to the students the
students are paying 70 80 grand a year
to go to these universities stop the
bloat that will reduce the cost of
tuition stop the federal guarantees that
will reduce the cost of admission stop
donating all of your money that will
reduce the cost of admission that will
stop this below that's going on at these
universities it will make them respond
to you because the prop don't blame the
Marxist professor professors or Marxists
this happens almost all the time
don't blame the students blame the
administrators and call for their jobs
to be surrendered call for them to be
fired call for them to be defunded all
right we got a lot more to get to but
it's a big day and we have that big
Alabama law so we will have much
to talk about tomorrow don't forget get
your mailbag questions and for Thursday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today a law at Alabama would outlaw
abortion in almost every case making no
exceptions for rape the left of course
to put it mildly
is not happy about this I sense that
maybe the tide is turning in America in
favor of the pro-life cause am I being
too optimistic well that would certainly
be a first but we'll talk about it also
someone emails someone emailed me and
asked whether conservatives are putting
their heads in the sand when it comes to
gun violence is that true are we well
I'll address that question today over on
the Matt Walsh show